hello and welcome back to Al Fame today
I'll work on the layouts of the coasters
as well as some terraforming and path
work to get a general good idea of what
it's going to look like without the
scenery before I get into theming the
ride now one thing I want to say about
this video though is that it's a little
bit different from usual I for one maybe
time-lapses a little bits would mess
fast they're ten times better off which
is not much less than the usual twelve
times but it's still a bit less I also
cut out some parts of the time lapses
and then there were some parts of making
these layouts that I just didn't record
for the reason that I don't think me
building coasters works quite as well
with the time lapse format as it does
with making scenery just because there's
a lot more camera movement involved with
the tweaking of the layouts and
smoothing and out and seeing exactly
where it's gonna go and that's basically
why I wanted to cut out some of the bad
parts do not make this video too crazy
in terms of lot of shaky camera movement
and all that stuff there was also the
fact that at the end I actually felt my
entire hard drive so I couldn't record
the very last part of making these
layouts but yeah there is a general idea
to making these coasters which I do want
to explain a bits
it's basically boils down to a lot of
inspiration from nemesis and dragon
challenge I think I've talked about
nemesis a little bit in the last video
it's you might probably say the best one
of the best inverts in the world it's in
Alton Towers and it's really beautiful
terrain conforming inverts it never gets
really high from the ground but it still
has pretty heavy layouts and beautiful
scenery and paths interaction around it
as well and I took a lot of inspiration
from nemesis for this ride there is
actually quite an exhibit in the
elements in the order of the elements of
these coasters since much like nemesis
this these coasters are going to start
out with a corkscrew into a zero-g roll
a looping in the lowest section of the
layouts and finally another corkscrew
before they entered a station even
though the parts between the elements
are completely different and the general
layouts is obviously going to be vastly
different there is the very similar
order of element
there but aside from that I would say
there is quite a bit of dragon challenge
influence in here since well the color
scheme is a bit similar even though it
is just a placeholder is called a color
scheme I might just change that at some
point in the future I'm not sure how big
of a fan I am of this one but dragon
challenge is the only dueling inverted
coaster in the world so that's pretty
much the only reference I have for it
but it's not a train coaster so that's
one thing that makes a difference and
why it wasn't actually as big of an
influence for this ride as you might
think most of it is definitely down to
nemesis but there is quite a bit of
uniqueness to this run as well since the
first section of the ride is going to
have these coasters basically
side-to-side and doing a lot of elements
together and interacting lot with each
other strikes while the trains kind of
pass each other and that's something
that dragon challenge doesn't really
have hell I think they don't even
synchronize anymore which is kind of a
shame but they have like complete
different layouts which don't interact
as much at least not side to side in a
sort of zigzag pattern as these coasters
do and I figured it would be nice to
actually have these coasters go well
pretty much next to each other until
they hit the middle of the track where
they split apart and pretty much do
their own thing and that's the very
basic idea of this layouts and starting
off I had a sort of nemesis beginning
kind of part with the curve into the
first corkscrew on that hill over there
which both coasters kind of interlock
with the corkscrews and go over each
other which is pretty fun and the next
element that I wanted to get in over
here which was a bit tight might want to
look at that a little bit more in the
future is going to curve into a
zero-zero over the lift Hill which I
figured for one it's well an element
that fits him pretty well off the record
school like this but it's also you know
it provides a fun sort of Rini over the
lift Hill in the pretty prominent zero-g
roles that are symmetrically are
symmetrically placed over the lift Hill
and also kind of have a near-miss in
them as well I wanted to have the like
feats of the cars to nearly hit each
other as you go out of the zero-g roll
so that's why both the coasters
have a 0:04 facing the other way just so
you kind of have that near-miss effect
in the coasters one of the things in
which I might get back to look at are
the zero zero specifically though
because there is no heart lining in them
one of the things which kind of bothers
me about this smooth tool is that even
though there is a heart lining feature
in the game which is amazing something
I've always wanted basically it is
pretty much on darkness as soon as you
start smoothing them out you can
probably kinda tell as I'm smoothing out
these zero-g rolls over here they lose a
lot of their shape but they also lose
their heart lining so they turn into
some you know decently smooth zero-g
rolls in the end but they don't have
much in the way of heart lining so I'm
gonna have to tweak that probably at
some point in the future and go about
that very carefully and many Lee to make
it a bit more realistic because just
some handmade pirate lining for a second
here it doesn't really cut it yet but
that's something I'm gonna have to look
at in the future anyway I did a very
quick test one over there which I cut
out and it's pretty much annoying
lighting now but that's not too big of
an issue for a coaster building so
pretty much just went on for this day
the next thing that I wanted to have is
a zigzag elements which is kind of
unusual for well an inverted coaster I
don't know about Jove enola one of the
tough things about this as you might
notice is that it's a Jove Enola goes
through instead of a BM inverts which is
simply because the BN m inverse comes
with a color scheme that doesn't really
fit the theme I figured and the G and
the Java know liqueurs just fit it a bit
more but there's only one Java NOLA
coaster in real life and I think the
only real difference is that it has from
bnm coasters is that it features more
helixes and has a double cork screw
which is unbeaten like but for pretty
much all purposes this is basically to
bnm inverts with java no liqueurs on it
that's what I would figure in any case
but I don't think there is any kind of
zigzag element not in this kind of sense
on an EP and I'm inverts but since I
have the two tracks together and I think
it would be fun to have a part where the
coaster tracks just curve
well next to each other and in and out
of each other and over each other and
just kind of do that interchangeably for
a while and have these exact element
that way before I had into the low part
because as you can already see I'm
starting to develop this little valley
underneath the console where I'm gonna
want to have the lowest parts of the
inverts so before I head into that I
still had a lot of speed over here so I
needed well to do something over here
and lose bit of the speed of the
coasters and that's why I wanted to have
this high zigzag part here but after
this part they are going to dive
straight into that valley after they do
a little turn around here and have the
deepest points of the ride which is
gonna be the looping much like nemesis
actually or which is also going to be
like the most eye-catching parts of the
layouts in terms of having also two
paths around the looping and things like
that which is unlimited like but yeah
before I went into that I still had to
turn the tracks around and you know that
might probably be some people who are
wondering how the hell I got these
things to synchronize that was basically
the answer I pretty much this how to do
lot of trial and error over here one of
the things which is really handy about
this coaster building system though is
since it offers a lot of flexibility and
you can just well test the coasters live
you can just kind of keep on going with
a trial and error to you see if you can
get them synchronized basically the red
one was lagging behind for quite a while
here so I just lowered a bunch of parts
of the red layouts and raised a bunch of
parts of the purple layouts and that
pretty much did the job so pretty happy
with how that works and they doing the
unsink out really well which I am going
to not show off anytime soon I'm
probably only showing off in the final
video but it's definitely something
which I'm really happy with and I'm
moving on the looping in the middle of
the valley is surprisingly well easy
actually to get the shape in a decent
kind of manner it's definitely not a
perfect looping but I'm still quite
happy with how it turned out its
symmetric or at least
and it is actually pretty easy to get
that very slight side where he stilts to
be able to get back to the ground beside
the track where you go up the general
shape of the looping in that sort of
oval kind of teardrop shape and is
actually something which I am pretty
happy with how it turned out I tried a
few looping before to see how I I could
make them in the best way possible but
they ended up becoming a bit too round
and I am pretty happy with how the shape
of these in the end has become though I
had a few issues with the smoothing too
a couple of times because the smoothing
tool and inversions is still sometimes a
bit of an issue and some something to
really get used to as well and on
corkscrews and loopings it might just
out of the blue starts twisting your
tracks in very strange ways which can be
kind of annoying now this is the part
where I wanted to lower the purple
coaster because it oh yeah that was
actually it I think yeah I needed to
lower the no no no I'm pretty sure I
needed to raise the red coaster and I
think I did that off-screen pretty sure
I did
but I'm yeah I think the purple coaster
was the one which was faster than the
red coaster for quite a while anyway I
took some off-screen time there to fix
the synchronization on the coasters and
it should be more or less ok now after
the looping they can't split ways and
just go in two separate directions
partly because I felt it would be fun to
divide it into two sections that way and
sort of give them more freedom to go
wherever I needed them to go in the
second half of the coaster and also
partly because it just makes my life a
bit easier since there were still some
empty areas and I wanted to make sure
that every single part of this valley
would be filled with some coaster paths
and scenery interaction so I wanted
these coaster layouts to go and use the
available space in this valley pretty
well and go through as much of the
scenery and the paths as I could and
hence why I figured it would be handy to
have the purple coaster go over here so
it can do some stuff over here have a
tight little helix and finally hook up
back to the station and have the red
cursor on the other side of the valley
and then it's basically the plan is just
an element's where it turns around over
here because I needed the cursor to turn
around and then there's the helix
because a very tight helix really felt
like something that I needed to get in
these fights and I didn't have yet so I
at least wanted to make sure that both
sides had a tight helix and the
corkscrew but aside from that there is
just a lot of playing about with the
exact ways that I needed healing outs to
go that was also a bit of annoying path
work over here because there's basically
terraforming everywhere but I wanted to
avoid having to use bridges for this
terraforming because it just makes life
a lot easier when I get to scenery if
the paths are attached to the ground
instead of being bridges that go
everywhere but I'm pretty happy with how
the paths turned out in the end though I
have to say many of the parts aren't
strictly very functional or they're for
park planning purposes they're more or
less just there to provide the
interaction between the coasters and the
paths and to provide a nice setting
because in the end I do want to turn
this into an Elvish village kind of idea
and to be able to do that a little bit
more well I figured it would be nice to
have this around here and just make sure
that those paths going just about
everywhere also just in case that I
might add some utilities restaurants
restrooms and things like that
throughout the park eventually now
cutting a bits in time as well I think
or that was actually pretty strange code
anyway cutting a bit I wanted to get to
the and this was actually pretty tough
points I wanted to get to the transfer
track of the red coaster and this was
kind of annoying because I wanted to get
transfer tracks in but I kind of got
myself into a corner here and there
wasn't a lot of space left so I really
had to curve this outward quite a bit to
have enough space for the transfer track
here I had to move the purple transfer
track to the other side of the purple
coaster and have the red transfer track
over here which is just about tied tight
enough I for you to make the area a bit
Bengt but not too tight it's not too
much like a dog crammed into one very
small corner but I did want to make this
path go over the transfer tract here
because obviously I still needed to hook
up the exit and the entrance for the
queue so that was kind of a tough corner
to make it all hook up over here the
queue is basically just gonna run around
the console and have a switchback
section at some point on the other side
of the console which is going to make
for a somewhat lengthy queue but then
again that's a good thing and I don't
think the queue layout is too bad and
this also provides a pretty good space
for the little path that hooks up from
the exits to actually go into that area
because the area where I just kind of
expanded the terraforming is where I
wanted to have little valley and make
sure that the red coaster does its thing
with just about the same length as the
purple coaster anyway that's about it
for the time-lapse so I'm gonna skip
forward to my real time partner here
alright so this is what it looks like a
little bit later or maybe an entire
stream later there's a bit of extra
terraforming done but one of the things
to really keep in mind is that this is
all very work in progress the only thing
that's really finished at the moment are
the coaster layouts themselves but truth
be told I kind of want to keep the way
that they runs a secret for the final
video but I am really happy with how the
general layouts of them came out with
having the very high up section where
they still do and say exactly Lots until
the loopings where they kind of split
ways over here and I do feel it's got a
decent sort of sense of compactness to
it like there's just about enough
interaction between the parts and the
coasters yet at the same time enough
space left to have some scenery around
this area and turn it into this elven
village kind of idea without making it
too cramped and one of my favorite sight
lines is definitely still here and one I
definitely want to keep clear as well
this over here definitely I should use
that where the bitless well presents a
really awesome view of the castle anyway
the general idea is that I do still need
to hook up the queue over here and turn
this into an area I hope to have some
extra like high up elven buildings over
here to provide the connection to the
council because at the moment it's kind
of hard to see what the final scenery is
gonna look like this is really the naked
layout so it's gonna look a lot
different with all the scenery in place
as well but also something to keep in
mind is that the cancer at the moment is
like a really standalone thing and I
want to you know make it somewhat
connected with the rest of the scenery
in this area somehow so I might add like
arches on the sides and in any case I
want to add some more heavy buildings on
this side I might get into some flat
rides but I do want to get into
restaurants and toilets and shops and
that kind of stuff just some general
scenery of the elven village to make it
a little bit nicer but this is the
general idea and this is what I'm gonna
work with something that I do have to
note now that I have the time to do so
and it seems pretty relevant to talk
about it at the moment is that I am
working on this on this project
basically to get it in for their
competition that's due on July the 1st
and that is a very close deadline and I
don't really have a lot of time to work
on this until that that line comes so I
am more or less focusing on the final
product right now instead of making
videos of this like I make videos of
this because I record the time lapses
now and then which is nice and a nice
byproduct of the making of this coaster
but the final product itself is the most
important part for me for this so I
might just do a lot of stuff off screen
and only two time lapses of what I think
is most worthy of doing time lapses of
so stuff like the heavy scenery of
buildings restaurants making the
stations that kind of stuff but I might
just leave out the things like adding
Rock work underneath the coasters
because even though I definitely still
want to feature some of it it's kind of
a repetitive thing and I'm gonna have to
do a lot of it considering the scale of
this thing
same goes for foliage so there's gonna
be a lot of stuff that I'm gonna want to
do off screen or maybe in streams and in
that sense this is gonna be a bit of a
different project than usual since the
focus isn't really to make this a video
series but I'm making these coasters and
just making these time lapses and random
videos of it's just to update on it I do
reckon the majority of the making-of is
still gonna get time lapsed but just
keep in mind that it's not going to be
as much as I usually would do but yeah
this is the look of the coasters I'm
gonna work on it a bit off screen to
provide a good base for the actual
scenery because at the moment it's still
kind of a mess in terms of part work and
terraforming it's just a very rough
sketch and this mess over here needs to
be fixed as well I'm probably gonna add
a little bit of foliage and rock work on
the lower sections to make sure that's
all done and provide a good sort of
foundation for the scenery in the next
episode so thank you guys for watching
and I'm gonna get right back to work